citizens of the rejection it's me Terry Erickson
alongside this guy say your name wow that
was a good job we are watching Despicable
Me which I have not seen but you have I saw
it uh when it first came out again my rule
of thumb is if I saw it once but don't remember
it I could join for a first time rewatch but
I haven't seen the sequels so I figured if
this goes well we could do the follow-ups
I haven't seen that or minions or anything
like that yeah domino effect exactly okay
well we better get into it but before we do
you guys need to leave a like you need to
leave a comment and you also need to ring
that ring the bell oh that felt good if you're
not patrons you should like get on top of
that because you could sync up with your own
copy and watch a full video reaction with
me and Gregory watching Despicable Me which
is crazy like the entire movie so get on that
super sexy reject nation and become a patron
now let's watch the movie
I just remember when I saw this the first
time I got into a big fight with someone beforehand
so I was PTSD right now paying attention he
was thinking about his fight the first time
he saw it I just remembered that take my picture
[Music] Justin reminds you of Sid from Toy
Story yeah just a blown up version yeah okay
stop child stop right there
[Music]
oh it's a fakie I've got him I've got him
okay I popped the pyramid that's no good Great
Pyramid of Giza had been stolen and replaced
by a giant inflatable replica Panic throughout
the globe as countries and citizens try to
protect their beloved landmarks
oh my goodness
[Music]
oh
looking in straight into your future kid that
could be so traumatizing to do a little boy
life is traumatizing it's about time that
I get my way
Despicable Me I like this song this has an
actual theme song yeah all right hello friend
your dog has been leaving little Bombs all
over my yard you know dogs they go wherever
they want to go unless they're dead oh my
God cookies for sale go away I'm not home
uh yes you are leave a message beep
some fella just stole a pyramid they're saying
he makes all other villains look lame Oh I
thought they were implying that he stole it
yeah they're just telling him he's a lame
villain now
okay okay
I feel like it's become so easy to hate these
guys but they are so freaking cute they're
very adorable we installed the Times Square
jumbo
NBC Universal we stole the Statue of Liberty
whoa the small one from Las Vegas we have
located the shrink ray and once we take this
God always wanted a shrink ray how cool would
that be I don't want anything shrunken we
are going to steal he's gonna shrink the Moon
is that what he just said okay lead to the
world ending yes I've been crunching some
numbers I really don't see how we can afford
these I'll just get another loan from the
bank they love me oh my God all the banks
are villains you won't be able to see at night
man these first time rewatches are always
so fun for me to see what jogs my memory and
what doesn't yeah like have you remembered
any of it
I'm kind of real life
Edith what did you put on my desk my pie you're
never gonna get adopted Ada I do not like
this lady oh we sold 43 mini mints 30 taco
swirlies and 18 coconutties oh look at the
photos
oh no let her out or is it almost Tim burtonesque
dark humor to this movie yeah just so you
know Mom I'm about to do something because
my everybody big when you hear about it you're
going to be very proud good luck with that
okay I'm out of here
cool glasses cool kick mom
nice
I
like how the animation has this sort of uh
1950s spy quality yeah it's kind of like noir-ish
yeah sort of incredible slant you know yeah
yeah adjacent cruel to see Mr Perkins oh I
get it it's his own separate evil Bank okay
I know right I thought it was like Chase Bank
and here's our security ball I was like yeah
right weird world someday I'm going to go
to the Moon oh I'm afraid you're too late
son oh the Moon is personal NASA isn't sending
the monkeys anymore
she loves you on the Inside Man trust me I
know what it's like poor Gregory I'm applying
for a new villain loan go by the name of vector
that's Jason Siegel because I'm committing
crimes with both Direction and magnitude oh
yeah why is he thrusting when he says that
also Vector I don't know about that loan in
that tracksuit buddy you have any idea of
the capital that this bank has invested a
new crew view of your Sinister plots actually
turning a profit oh if we don't start getting
our money back oh I thought he was actually
respected I apparently not by the bank like
that young fellow out there named Victor he
just stole a pyramid oh maybe the tracksuit
is working after all [Music] that is diabolical
[Music]
infant four no I hope the shrinking doesn't
hurt it can't be violent would it I assume
it's just like oh you're shrunken now and
you don't even realize it right
that does look painful oh
why is everyone undermine her when he seems
like he's pretty capable
oh my goodness it's so dumb do you know who
voices the minions I don't know who voices
them no they just like blabber right yeah
but there's gonna be a voice behind it though
Vector got your back now maybe you'll think
twice before you freeze someone's head we
can't let you give away [Music] like how their
ships feel like they're from two different
eras yeah
[Music] great
whoa Overkill yeah why but also taking one
chance on all of them like release them slowly
adorable
[Music] what is going oh at least he's not
shrinking
[Music] wow that could have been really violence
in another movie [Music] what he's got a shark
dang Factor
Jesus
oh my God
I like
the inventions and the amalgamations of all
these like villain tropes yeah also that he's
still alive whoa cool cool we're selling cookies
so you know we can have a better future do
you have coconutties uh yeah oh Vector loves
him coconutties
[Music] oh my goodness this is what he imagines
that's hilarious you have made a list of some
of your personal achievements foreign
[Music]
[Music] oh
so cute I can't stand it
okay girls let's go [Music]
my memories was telling me that he adopted
them at the very end I thought you like for
some reason like like love them and then adopted
them at the end
fluffy donkey
[Music] an appropriate place for little kids
that's a precocious teenager oh no stay away
from
no well I suppose the plan will work with
two [Laughter] oh I poked a hole in my juice
box oh I suppose the plan will work right
here provided everything a child might need
oh my God oh my God no oh no we're gonna be
really happy here right it's like they replaced
one orphanage for another yeah oh at least
the food is candy how could he enjoy the minions
but not like kids
what's out of these yeah what are they for
cookie robots I said cookie robots where are
all those Boogie robots gonna go now [Music]
uh oh she's gonna go to the oh she's not in
there come on I thought she killed the dog
oh that's cool I would sign up for that
I meant to close that and here of course is
the new weapon you ordered
[Music] art gun not oh because I was wondering
under what circumstances would we use this
[Music] now those are cooking robots that's
why you keep them around I am a spy may not
tell anybody because if you do
oh no you have to it has been disintegrated
by divination it cannot be fixed oh
what is she doing she's gonna hold her breath
until she gets a new one
okay
you have to get the little girl a new unicorn
toy [Music]
I like how I know it has a name for all of
them Jerry Stewart watch them and keep them
away from me please they all have like mediocre
white man names thank you Steve Mark Matt
oh my God it's been a while since I've seen
a movie that is just incredibly adorable I'm
like you're kidding it
[Music] Jesse
[Music]
oh karaoke girl get in there
what is the screenplay when it comes to the
minions how do they write that okie dokie
belly bye I get to sleep in sweet uh no those
are bombs are these beds made out of bombs
[Laughter] will you read us a bedtime story
no but we can't go to sleep without a bedtime
story she is so cute she's the cutest thing
I've ever seen foreign [Music]
oh yes oh my God they look like so much alike
too yes we can't keep the dance class today
we have a big recital coming up we're doing
an excerpt from Swan Lake yeah Swan Lake I
know that from Black Swan if you want to go
you are going to have to walk yourself
you're dealing with independent orphans man
yeah man and one
oh you are coming right of course of course
Pinky Promise my pinky promises
he doesn't know how to love because his mother
didn't love him is that why you're so broken
yeah yeah and successful Girls welcome back
to the Fortress of Victor tude you got my
cookies for me oh it is an evil plan to use
little children to be doing this sure is
[Music]
wow nine are you wearing pajamas this is a
warm-up suit [Music] dang those cookie robots
are capable of a lot more than I thought what
are you warming up for super cool stuff you
wouldn't understand like sleeping like sleeping
oh that's so funny [Music] Mission Impossible
minions [Music] oh my God how frustrating
oh
[Music] oh that's super smart I see foreign
[Music]
I
can't quite pinpoint it but somehow this movie
has got me to root for Gru oh yeah even though
he's despicable you though he's a Despicable
Me I I don't know exactly how they've done
it laughs well I get maybe it's because he's
the underdog villain and this guy's like a
real dum-dum yeah drink it
oh if he does shrink it and this is probably
not made in the time of Baby Shark Song right
but that would be perfect
did they just murder that guy don't care please
please
[Music] oh man this guy oh sorry dude they
can't ride without an adult [Music] they can't
rather than adult but the three of them could
ride in the front of the car okay that makes
sense with no seat belts [Music]
On My Feet
oh
oh that's cute oh my gosh look at that fluffy
unicorn
[Music]
oh my god well it is not for sale but all
you gotta do to win it is knock down that
little spaceship there it's check my prayers
voice again [Music] oh [Applause] [Music]
hello
scam again
[Music] come on guys I feel like it would
be possible to win
oh damn you see how it's not knocked over
you have to actually knock it over me
fatherly protection get it grow oh you're
the real one amazing what is that thing
Oh yay love the Unicorn survived [Music] I
love how you're not freaked out there by the
Let's Go destroy another game
soft real we can't afford any distractions
you would want to see this [Music]
well done grew rather impressive now the rest
of the plan is simple things get unshrunk
I shrink them all I grabbed the moon I sit
on the toilet with what sorry
can we order pizza whatever just get back
in there can we get stuffed crust
I was saying
believe me I am completely focused all right
hello oh no [Music] no no no no no
whoops I've seen quite enough but my plan
is a great plan except for one thing you oh
look Mom I drew a picture of me landing on
the moon [Music] look Mom I made the real
rocket based on the macaroni
ah
there's a random poignant element about the
trauma he has we're gonna put our faith into
a well a younger villain but it's over but
he got the shrink ray oh my goodness I'm sure
you guys could pull off this plan without
the bank I know there have been some rumors
going around the bank is no longer funding
us I am here to put those rumors to rest they're
all true they are true you do remember now
would probably be a good time to look for
other employment options
can't you see that I'm in the middle of the
pep talk
that's so sweet
catcher scientists like invent money [Music]
look at all that stolen money one big happy
stealing family [Music]
[Music]
what are you doing here what here he is what
here is all dressed up in his Sunday best
he looks like a girl an ugly girl
what did you do
things are just better in pink sometimes
[Music]
Mr Perkins your son is here send him in oh
his son is the real oh okay now it all makes
sense do you know where the shrink gray is
back in my place oh is that right I guess
just have one that looks exactly like it oh
and he knows the three little girls too late
so Cru sees my latest weapon [Music] don't
worry the Moon is good as ours this whole
movie is about parenting the entire movie
well I Empire will you read us a bedtime story
sleepy kittens what are these puppets use
the money to tell the story um Three Little
Kittens love to play they had fun in the sun
all day I love this story Mommy we're not
tired at all their mother smiled and said
with the par fine but at least you should
brush your fur oh my God he's the mama kitten
oh yes to brush them we feel too rushed and
mother replied with a voice like Silk fine
but at least you should drink your milk now
make them drink the milk
oh it's Interactive good night kittens though
while you sleep we are apart your mommy loves
you with all her heart he's realized real
life the end okay good night we're both goodnight
kisses oh that is so sweet oh my God he's
not gonna kiss us good night Agnes I like
him he's nice
this family is so freaking cute yeah maybe
we could move the date of the heist this is
not as a result of the girls dance recital
is it stupid I the weird to do Saturday
you and I have been working on this for years
they need to go you don't do something about
it and I will oh no nefario don't you dare
he seems actually villainous yeah
we put our cups together we will make the
clink sound with our mouths ready oh tea party
he is a little too distracted by this there's
no way he's going to be able to steal the
Moon while also teaching tea parties to these
kids what are you doing here I'm here for
the girls I received a call that you wanted
to return them what I didn't like what you
said
oh nefario called that is messed up that is
too far
it's gonna make me cry you can't just return
kids okay don't let her take us Mr Gru maybe
in the like Foster system you can Goodbye
Mr Gru thanks for everything oh my God no
that is so sad I hate it it's gonna make me
cry he's gonna steal him out of the car I
can't handle this pain it's too much emotional
pain
how to go get them back come on let's go get
that Moon the Moon means nothing without family
that is too cold man he's gonna be so sad
and so is everybody else [Music] please
they're racing oh my God she built two more
boxes of Shame I'm gonna put them in the box
of Shame y'all need to build a big one and
shove her in there and do not let her out
[Music]
I love how it's about him accomplishing a
childhood dream he plays on someone wanted
to be an astronaut the side though I I am
the greatest Criminal Mind of the century
I don't go to little golf dance recital
they're going to get to you I really like
the way the motion is captured too
in this movie
[Music] it's like dark and dim that it's all
this movie is still very colorful like the
whole time oh yeah which I love very Lush
colors yeah
squid it to death that's not gonna work [Music]
oh that was easy all right see you later Vector
my flight suit
oh yeah once again
[Music]
the way they reflect stuff into their eyes
in this movie is awesome yeah yeah
[Music] I guess as long as they have the moon
I forget but like no I mean yeah
I've got it I've got the moon I guess crew's
been to space before because he seems awfully
relaxed yeah yeah
it means nothing you're so good people you
still make it to the recital I can make it
yeah hurry thank you
oh oh no the effects are not long lasting
oh but how long is the last one that's what
I'm saying I'm like that guy seems like he
was shrunken for like two days laces no we
can't start yet we're still expecting someone
and we just wait a few more minutes
quick we have to warn him and fast oh man
that Moon's gonna blow up Studio
okay
I
really love the vibe of when this we're actually
with the cities and the buildings and stuff
oh it's over no he's way late
call them dad um that's so sad it breaks my
heart
uh Vector just big V
[Music] how is the earth still functioning
without the Moon [Music]
kids off somewhere I don't know I think I'll
hold out to them a little while when you are
in in the world of pain
how does he avoid this oh freeze yourself
where's your freeze gun
won't this attack is house this is a stupid
plan
what no way all right man oh my God he's getting
his villain skills back I didn't know he could
do that
from the Shadows a hero Rises
yes [Music]
there he is
at least this guy is actually loyal yeah
catch him catch him oh great timing what happened
to the ship not as big as the moon's going
to be what the larger the mass of an object
the quicker the effects of the shrink ray
we're off hello [Music]
hey what are you girls doing back there how
do you not sense any of this yeah come on
vector [Music] oh okay yes
[Music]
run what fun little adventurous
oh cool [Music] you're going to have to jump
don't worry I will catch you you gave us back
yeah and it is the worst mistake I ever made
oh this movie is so sweet yeah [Music]
okay get Margo [Music]
no no let me go oh my god oh no no no no no
no no no no
come on nefario
this guy's so stupid so dumb oh this is stressing
me out man I don't like it again no [Music]
yay
oh
yo this guy's gonna get crushed hey man you
wanted the moon you got it
can't kill off people once again law enforcement
is baffled leaving everyone to wonder who
is this mysterious hero and what will he do
next camera three sleepy kittens oh no sorry
that that book was accidentally destroyed
maliciously
one big unicorn by who wrote this oh me uh
oh no it's a puppet book here was this
[Laughter] one big unicorn strong and free
thought he was happy as he could be then three
little kittens came around and torn his whole
life upside down that's really sweet they
made him laugh they made him cry he never
should have said goodbye and now he knows
he could never part from those three little
kittens they changed his heart
all right good night
give him the kisses yeah [Music] oh
[Music] [Laughter]
all right
this movie is so sweet makes me cry ah
he's doing a whole Adventure saddle oh [Music]
[Laughter]
very good ah I'm so proud of you son what
you're crazy just like me maybe even [Music]
better okay
yeah where are those Boogie robots
let loose grow come on man [Music] start with
the shoulders start with the shoulders
oh never mind oh okay full on
foreign
disco dancing was the best you would know
yeah I would yeah I was like 30 in the 70s
what are you celebrating yeah man he just
likes it up there on the moon
cool
oh that was so good I cried yeah man oh man
when she said I love you oh it's gonna make
her cry again I just feel like coming back
up
what's happening I don't know where are they
measuring to oh
oh we don't get to find out thank you
was moving a 3D or something maybe it was
it must be 3D yeah what a fascinating way
to get you to stick around yeah
there it is ah okay
[Music] very impressive
looks like Alfred Hitchcock
okay there we have it Julie Andrews was Gru's
mom what Pierre coffin I have no idea who
that is me neither he's the minions cool all
right I like him well Tara five stars five
five out of five five out of five five out
of five nine point nine stars out of ten that
movie was fun and so heartfelt yeah like I
wasn't expecting that I I wasn't expecting
to be as engrossed as you were yeah I was
like just paying attention the whole time
like I I like just being kind of lost in here
I wasn't even really joking around and watching
it I know we were we were really just watching
around more with this serious movie yeah yeah
yeah that was really fun I I I I I like how
they have these like little poignant touches
throughout with Gru of this whole thing with
his mom and him not repeating the cycle of
his mom right would actually be becoming a
good pair to you see that all his villainy
is all stem from this place of just seeking
approval yeah yeah but that's seeking approval
is he just wanted love his whole life and
then he finds love with his children it's
such a weird plot it's such a strange and
it's so funny because like the mom comes at
the end and is like I'm proud of you yeah
right just like added kind out of nowhere
a little bit where it's like oh she sees that
he's become like a parent and what she was
like I'm proud of you but for what the parenting
thing right that's what the mom was saying
but he doesn't even really need it right at
this point that's what I'm saying like it's
kind of just like oh whatever it's we've gotten
over that now Mom like I know now what true
love is which would mean they accepted him
from day one which any other kid would be
like you're scary and this is weird and they
were just like hey you want to hang out you
want to play with us I mean especially Edith
if it's our character like the entire house
because she's like the weird kid she's like
me when I was a kid um but uh I I liked that
I think the the theme yes parenting but also
like true love because they showed him that
from day one they never like judged him it
was always just like they they just saw him
for what he was and welcomed like whatever
he brought to the table with Open Hearts and
open minds yeah they just wanted a parent
they just wanted a parent right yeah but I
like the dark sense of it's not like a dark
humor but there's a I would say dark in the
way of how people say not even quite this
much but like an Adam's family kind of dark
where it doesn't feel dark there's a Macabre
kind of humor to it yeah where it's it's not
the typical kind of kids humor you would expect
where they're they're willing to touch on
at like the way they make fun of the whole
orphanage side of things yeah or how how much
Guru does like to bully or how he wishes ill
will you know yeah I think a lot of that was
was really funny and uh and kind of refreshing
I really I I I sincerely uh incorrectly remembered
it I thought that it for some reason my mind
I remembered that Gru wanted to be a super
villain and something with the little kids
and my mind was telling me that he adopted
them at the very end of the movie and I guess
he kind of did adopt him because he returned
them so maybe that's what my mind was telling
me was like he got the method but I I feel
like if you get them the second time you're
like you're keeping them but this whole thing
with this Vector guy and and and uh using
the kids as a ploy to be able to get them
that not a single recollection of so most
of this did feel like pretty bright like a
brand new film yeah yeah it felt like very
brand new to me and uh weirdly I I wonder
if I feel like when did this come out do you
have any idea anyway I don't I'm assuming
like early 2000s let me see if we can say
my God that's so loud I hate that noise let
me see here it'll probably say right it should
2010 2010. I honestly feel like at I mean
uh
uh I I imagine I would have liked it but man
it's amazing how much I can forget I mean
I can watch a movie like one time like from
a few years ago and or like and not remember
right it's kind of wild right yeah be like
wow it it shocks me how how little my memory
information mine is also very bad yeah yeah
well 2010. I wanted to watch my words doesn't
remember 2010. because it was a kid's movie
but 2010 Greg was doing a lot Greg was weird
in 2010. he wouldn't have understood this
movie Greg was definitely using a lot of things
that started with a W it ended with a d you
know what I mean so oh yeah yeah yeah so yeah
I
[Music]
what is that what is that thing in in on our
memory no you know what I mean but like how
come we can't remember anything like with
a movie it's just bizarre to me how how little
like I can like see an image of something
and be like I know what that's from but then
if you want to know details oh I can't remember
but don't you feel like probably everyone
else on this channel or most people we know
would be like oh it's that and don't you remember
this plot and this plot and then this line
from this movie and I'm like I watch a lot
of movies and a lot of TV shows and I cannot
quote any of them I can't tell you what I
watched last month I would literally have
to go back to be like what's my viewing history
and then I can let you know because that was
so engrossed in this and I was so affected
by this movie too and I'm like I don't recall
granted I remember to get into a fight with
someone before this movie but I don't recall
being affected at all at all I didn't even
recall my any emotional uh uh attack I was
like I think it was funny that's what I remembered
my mind saying was like I remembered it being
funny I don't remember my heart actually being
really touched by it and maybe 2010 Greg just
wouldn't be you were just like too high and
or asleep yeah I was too cool for school man
yeah man he wasn't gonna cry no way would
you catch him doing that arms folded I punched
the person next to me exactly here uh but
no 20 23 Greg would uh he would cry I'd cry
he brings tissues I was that was so that was
a man bag so he can put tissues real men cry
or or or they can get out real men cry or
they can get the hell out get out yeah that's
what you're saying that's what I'm saying
we're saying I can get out no I'm saying what
are they what do you mean get out what am
I getting men can cry or they can say it together
get the heck out what I thought we were gonna
say it together but nope it's fine moments
over we lost the train of thought uh anyway
that was a little commentary it's a great
film what was your favorite moment of this
movie Gregory tell the people please who was
the I love you did you have a favorite moment
here oh oh my god um it's so fluffy I want
to die oh my god when she calls the unicorn
and she says it's so fluffy I want to die
that is my favorite line I love it so much
but yes obviously I mean it's like when he
I don't yes when he goes and gives him kisses
and then they all line up and he's like a
full-on dad slash parent now and villaining
doesn't mean so much now yeah he's gonna that
takes a villain takes a back seat to be in
a cool parent you know what I what you think
of the animation because the animation to
me was interesting because I like I like the
aesthetic Choice a lot of the the Espionage
old Flair to it that that felt like out of
a 60s cereal or something like that yeah um
like not Mission Impossible today but Mission
Impossible back the TV show you know yeah
wow yeah that kind of old school vibe to it
or like Bond you know from the 60s yeah and
so I like the aesthetic but I also thought
The the actual dimensions of things is relatively
simple you know like it doesn't seem like
it's trying to be this overly flashy anime
like it's still vibrant yeah like there's
something that's still simple about the way
it was done and yeah there's no like real
wide shots or anamorphic type like or a crane
or like a dolly where it's like it keeps moving
it's just sort of like basic tattoos Fields
yeah yeah or I don't want to like slide it
no I think it works for the story oh yeah
yeah it works it works so well that you don't
notice it until you think about it by going
like oh they could have tried too hard and
and put in a lot of like moving shots or shots
that take a long time but it was more just
like it was more basic in the way that it
was delivered which obviously still worked
you know what I liked about the structure
too that I thought was unique was that the
normally a story like this where you have
a very specific world you usually have some
type of Cipher for the audience some who they
can hand the exposition do you like you explain
it to them so as they're walking through the
store and they don't have that right they
just thrust you into the the story in the
world and you're learning as a like like with
the bank like I got to get it from the bank
and we're either being a character being like
go to the bank yes there's a villain for the
bank there's no one there's a villain Bank
through this yeah that's like how BBC does
it any good TV shows it is they do zero Exposition
they're just like we trust the audience let
them figure it out which I wholeheartedly
appreciate yeah BBC does that well and they
did that well here what'd you think of vector
I mean he was fine I mean he was once you
were like it's Jason Siegel I was like he's
hilarious like I liked the voiceover but um
he wasn't like he was a character that if
I thought of this movie I wouldn't really
think about him at all I would think about
the three girls yeah and uh and Guru and the
minions and that's it and I'd be like oh there
was some other guy there when a orange tracksuit
yeah not a very memorable character not really
right yeah I had no recollection I was like
okay yeah like oh he's in this but yeah yeah
it was necessary to have in it right for someone
to him to fight against but I didn't I didn't
I don't know I didn't feel very strongly about
him exactly that's probably the best way to
put it I didn't really I if there's anything
I could have used a bit of an enhancement
I thought maybe maybe right yeah like I like
what they set up too with him having the the
juxtaposition of the guru with his mom and
then vector and his dad I felt like there
was something thematically happening yeah
um but yeah it was very two-dimensional oh
that makes me think that like when the girls
were there with Vector what if they had like
changed him his character in the moment if
they had been there enough time touched him
in the same way that they touch grew in regards
to making um Vector think a little bit differently
not so differently that he wouldn't want the
moon back but maybe a little bit like they
could have had because Vector obviously has
similar problems with his bank dad right like
he's feels inferior um so in you saying that
I thought like oh it would have been cool
if there was a way that um I don't know maybe
the girls have affected him in some certain
way with like one little piece of information
and sort of made Vector wake up to go like
what do I actually like want to do I don't
know yeah like that's true I don't know how
they could do that but maybe maybe and the
girls were really adorable I they're so cute
the relationship was great I like how I like
the way how they they did Bond it went down
a direction I didn't expect because it was
it was playful and started off with annoyances
was like it has the trajectory that you could
see on like an outline of something but the
way they landed there like I like how it led
it started happening after he got to be himself
with taking out his big Arsenal weapon and
shooting down that that space thing in the
oh yeah yes Carnival thingy and yeah that
that opened the door for them to actually
Bond yeah because he saw that they would love
him even though he is like a villain with
real guns yeah they never viewed him as a
villain or even questions no they were just
like cool yeah I thought that was great those
kids were cool I wonder what the sequels are
about hmm because you got to keep the steam
going in some way right yeah I mean Vector
is still alive on the moon so is he still
or no he probably won't come back we got a
super villain world so we got it there's like
many we gotta get rid of actor there's a new
villain there used to fight right yeah we
got to get some new buildings what if the
girls are like they're like little mini super
villains now but they're like they're nice
they keep him grounded like they but they
make him fight for the right things instead
of the bad things like not shrink the moon
this person's mean or like you gotta go save
these people right they teach him to do be
like a good hero yeah you know I just realized
the movie that was so smart actually um was
they they plant the seed right away with his
change of heart other than like you you could
see it coming just because of the kids movie
that he would have a change of heart it's
his relationship with the minions because
the minions are so childlike and you could
see that he's very much endeared to them as
well he doesn't just even though they're called
Minions he doesn't just treat them like henchmen
you know right they're all named he he likes
he likes to get the good attention from them
he shows them love Yeah and even though they're
not human they're childlike so that is I think
there's like a subconscious endearment because
I could I kept trying to place like why am
I liking this guy why am I why am I rooting
for him because he called and you did initially
call it out when you were like he knows their
names yeah yeah it was really odd to me I
was like it's kind of weird how they all like
there's this large quantity of them and he
knows them all by name right yeah like when
he started naming them that may be like I
didn't notice it until you said something
and I was like oh yeah and then I realized
they're all like Mark Steve John um yeah yeah
yeah but I think that is sort of the subconscious
thing of like him at least knowing their names
that shows that he he cares he's not a total
jerk oh yeah right I like the old guy too
I thought it was gonna be like a full villain
nefario yeah they did a good uh job of like
riding the line of like is nefario just a
full-on jerky pants especially when he called
in the kids to be like send them back you're
like what the f but then he he does come through
for his friend and he saves them which is
nice and I think like obviously maybe in the
second one nefario probably builds a relationship
I would assume with the girls and now it's
like one big happy family he's realized like
these girls are cool well I'm excited um to
check out the the other ones uh even though
I like the minions a lot in this part of me
is having a hard time wrapping my brain around
a whole movie just about the minions like
what would that I mean because there's this
there's this thing that's happened in the
Zeitgeist of the world where minions are loved
obviously this was their introduction yeah
and then a lot of people I think they they
just started getting like promoted and shoved
and became like the the mascot yeah like Universal
Studios and illumination everywhere so people
started getting really annoyed by them yeah
um so I keep wondering if the movie will just
be annoying but we'd have to find Despicable
2 or you mean minions there's like an actual
movie Minions it's just about like the minions
like a prequel I don't know if I've seen it
I don't think I have I definitely haven't
seen it I I haven't seen it there's like two
like just Minions movies that were like released
in the theaters and we're like the only thing
I know is that is I know that because I've
been to Universal Studios and they said it
a lot and I always thought it was funny and
I'm always like banana I hated that that's
what I know hell well well well well I don't
it's not my favorite ride either anyhow uh
we love you all and what do I say at the end
uh what did you think about Despicable Me
should we watch the sequels guys you let us
know what you thought about this movie and
also let us know if we should react to the
other ones right very good did I do he's yeah
Bingo baby and also I mean if you haven't
I know what he's gonna say he's trying out
but I was gonna say if you aren't already
a super sexy Patron you should become one
you know yeah like I see you you see us Patron
it up Patron shout out here we go I want to
shout out Chris wamoth oh the reason why is
because this movie is about adoption and if
there's someone at our patreon I'd like to
adopt to be Chris whamla oh because this guy
is insanely selfless he's one of those those
like Warriors in the street who's been arrested
for fighting for people's rights wow Chris
he's a great guy and you want to have someone
like that as your child yeah absolutely because
no matter how crappy you treat that kid they'll
be nice to you they'll be nice and they will
always find a way to be like I I know it comes
from a place of love Daddy Greg yeah and uh
I'd want to be called daddy Greg too that
way it sounds like there's something creepy
going on
then I'm like no there's nothing creepy happening
with Chris and I that's my son and be like
well why do you have him call you Daddy Greg
it sounds like there's there's some kind of
Oddity happening here like that's just what
he calls me because I want him to call me
that yeah anyway um Chris I would love to
adopt you my friend and I think that you would
be the ideal candidate for inheriting real
rejects really wow I mean I am literally sitting
right here well let's just face it if if a
woman were to take over
well Daddy Gregory I've really I've heard
enough I could score some brownie points actually
with the public yeah because I'm a lady because
I look very Progressive yeah because I'm a
lady so let me consult with the other men
okay yeah see if that's go into your room
full of men and see if they want a lady to
run the real Rejects I bet you're gonna get
a lot of comments and people are gonna be
like let that lady run it and some people
are gonna call me a woman and some people
are going to be like we don't know this girl
but she might seem okay is it defensive to
say lady why I called myself a lady okay just
making sure oh lazy a woman a lady you know
I don't know we lost Greg I don't know just
like tell Chris you love him so we can all
go eat dinner now I am so hungry happy Birthday
Chris it's late we love you Chris I'm so glad
he adopted you before he even thought about
adopting me and I'm here all the time now
here's why we say goodbye yeah okay bye
illumination banana
foreign